foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I'm Perry nemeroff when it
comes to horror films one of the many
sub-genres that has popped up over the
years is that of spooky doll movies why
has it become such a thing well there's
something about combining the innocence
of Youth that a doll represents with
something awful and terrible like a doll
that loves to kill people that I can say
really appeals to me so there's that
with names here like Chucky Billy
Annabelle fat Brahms and more this list
has got you so well covered with some of
the most spooky dolls you can find in
movies and one classic TV episode thrown
in as well so turn your head around a
full 360 Degrees maybe and let's take a
look at our list of the scariest evil
dolls of cinema right now on RT
Essentials
the clown doll Poltergeist
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'll go check the kitchen no no I'm
creeping or rather kicking off this list
here is the clown doll from 1982's
Poltergeist this big budget Thriller was
directed by Toby Hooper and co-written
slash produced by Steven Spielberg who
many say also served as de facto
director while he hovered in the
background in it Craig T Nelson stars as
a man who moves his family to a new home
that ultimately becomes haunted by
demonic ghosts due to it being built on
top of an old graveyard and that's where
the clown doll comes in as it's
considered to be an aspect of the film's
main antagonist the Beast acting as one
of the other vengeful ghosts its main
purpose in Poltergeist is to basically
serve as a distraction so that other
ghosts can abduct the family's little
girl Carol Ann and by serve as a
distraction I mean totally mess with her
brother Robbie the pair's big scene
together involves the clown doll
eventually sneaking up behind Robbie and
pulling him under the bed to choke him
out
eventually Robbie fights back but at
that point if clowns weren't already
scary enough for some this particular
one was seared into the minds of kids
forever and adults too of course after
the making of the movie Spielberg didn't
like the film got an R rating and so he
appealed it and since PG-13 wasn't a
thing yet this movie is actually rated
PG so many traumatized kids out there
but hey a PG rating means more butts and
seeds and Poltergeist became the highest
grossing horror movie of 1982 and the
eighth highest grossing movie of the
year overall and while the clown doll
didn't exactly accept any awards
specifically this movie did win a bafta
award for best special visual effects it
was also nominated for an Oscar in the
same category but wound up losing it to
the big movie that Spielberg did
officially during direct that year E.T
of course
Billy saw
[Laughter]
[Music]
cutting through to the next spot on this
list is Billy from 2004's saw this film
was directed by James Wan in his
directorial debut and written by Lee
wanell two names you'll hear again later
on in this list let's just say they
really love working with creepy dolls
the story revolves around the mystery of
the jigsaw killer who likes to test his
victim's will to live by putting them
through potentially deadly and very
painful games and it turns out the guy
behind jigsaw is named John Kramer
played by Tobin Bell and Kramer is the
one who designed the mechanical
ventriloquist puppet known as Billy
Billy is a clown-like appearance with a
white face and red spirals on his cheeks
to go with his smiling red lips and
creepy black and red eyes the doll shows
up throughout what would go on to become
quite the franchise and usually comes in
Via video but is also known to appear in
in person too or rather dull I guess to
give the rules of the games to his
victims
hello Amanda
you don't know me but
I know you I want to play a game in this
first installment Billy makes a
memorable appearance at the end of the
movie when the cops find him at the bad
guy's hangout eerily hidden under a
blanket but he's actually first
introduced through a couple of flashback
scenes one when Adam played by writer
Lee 1l recalls the abduction that led to
him being trapped in a gross bathroom
with Carrie elos and again when the
movie looks back at the story of
jigsaw's only known Survivor a drug
addict named Amanda saw became one of
the more profitable horror films since
1996 his scream see our scariest evil
masks of Cinema episode for more on that
if we have one yet and as Saw's
popularity grew our Billy here became
the face of the franchise and speaking
of face that memorable mug of his has
popped up Easter egg style and other
works of Wands and one else so keep an
eye out for Billy just about everywhere
Annabelle Annabelle
[Music]
next on our list of the scariest evil
dolls of Cinema is Annabelle from 2014's
Annabelle produced by James Juan from
the aforementioned saw a franchise and
directed by John R leonetti this film is
a prequel to the 2013 movie The
Conjuring and focuses on the origins of
the popular Annabelle doll seen in that
film Annabelle which is the second
installment of The Conjuring Universe
tells the story of Jon played by Ward
Horton who tried to bring home the
perfect gift for his expectant wife Mia
played by Annabelle Wallace and yeah you
heard that right the lead actress in
Annabelle is also named Annabelle anyway
that gift an 18-inch vintage porcelain
doll in a fancy white dress ultimately
becomes cursed and dangerous after home
invading devil worshipers come in to
attack the couple and summon up some
demons
[Music]
Annabelle the doll was partially
inspired by a popular story in the
Paranormal Community told about a
raggedy and doll that is said to be
haunted and later lived in an occult
museum in Connecticut and according to
the lore of future Annabelle films the
doll first became possessed after the
daughter of a toy maker lost his
daughter Annabelle and accidentally
summoned a demon who claimed to be her
spirit and was transferred to one of her
dolls speaking of which Annabelle didn't
just earn one thumb in The Conjuring
Universe this one was followed by a
prequel the excellent Annabelle Creation
in 2017 and the sequel the also
excellent Annabelle comes home in 2019
both of which are fresh on the Tomato
Meter of course compared to this one
which is rotten Chucky Child's Play
I said talk to me dammit or else I'm
gonna throw you in the fire
[Music]
toying around in the next spot on this
list Chucky from 1988's Child's Play
This film was directed and co-written by
Tom Holland and is the first in what
would become a whole series of movies
featuring Chucky the doll in this one a
dying murderer named Charles Lee Ray
puts a soul inside a popular doll named
Chucky using black magic that doll Finds
Its way into the possession of a boy
named Andy and basically messes up the
poor kid's life Chucky a good guy doll
turned murderer in Child's Play Has the
strength of a full-grown man despite
being small in stature he was inspired
by the popular Cabbage Patch Kid dolls
from the 1980s a Twilight Zone episode
we'll talk about soon and the 100 plus
year old tale of a real-life haunted
doll named Robert
Andy no please
we're friends to the end remember
This is the End friends
as for Chucky's design look no further
than Hasbro's 1985 My Buddy doll which
also donned denim overalls and a striped
shirt I mean hey it's a solid look there
and The Man Behind Chucky is actor Brad
duruff who plays the dying killer that
transfers his soul and then later
provides the voice of Chucky and before
you go thinking Child's Play was
probably the highlight of this guy's
career it's worth noting that dwarf is
actually an oscar-nominated and Golden
Globe winning actor for his debut role
in 1975's One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest and he also played grima wormtong
in The Lord of the Rings series so
you're welcome while we're at it the
friendly voice of Chucky came from
eating gross who also voiced a doll
named Corky in the cricket doll series
and the in suit performer for Chucky
guess they did have one of those was Ed
Gail best known for playing Howard in
1986's Howard the Duck you are welcome
again Chucky helped build a child's play
franchise that includes six sequels a
reboot a TV series plus all that
beautiful merch Billy Dead Silence
making some noise next on this list is
Billy from the 2007 horror flick Dead
Silence once again this film was
directed by James Wan and written by Lee
wanell and is considered basically their
big follow-up to the previously
successful saw film turned franchise and
right off the bat you'll notice that the
puppet doll used in the Saw movies and
this one here in dead silence are both
named Billy I guess sorry to all you
viewers named Billy it's a pretty tough
break there this film revolves around a
widower played by Ryan quantin who
returns to his awesomely named hometown
of ravens fair to try and figure out the
story behind his wife's Grizzly death
and like any town with a name like that
there he stumbles upon the legend of a
murdered ventriloquist whose Eerie
presence not to mention Eerie doll named
Billy still looms heavy over the town
she's living in the dark
the voice of Billy is provided by
Enright tell whose impressive career in
the booth includes video game voices
within the Star Wars Batman Lord of the
Rings GoldenEye and Marvel franchises
just to name a few there sadly this
Billy couldn't help Juan and wanel kick
off a new franchise as Dead Silence was
universally panned by critics and
performed poorly at the box office of
course that meant no sequel or sequels
but a cult following has since built up
for the movie and if Billy is looking
for something to hang his red bow tie on
he did also appear in a dead silence
themed haunted house during Universal
Studios Halloween Horror Nights in
Florida now how many of these creepy
dolls can say that huh I'm sure that
eases the sting a little of a critic's
consensus that says dead silence is
undone by Boring characters or or maybe
not I am sincerely sorry Billy
Taki Tina The Twilight Zone my name is
Eric Streeter
[Applause]
[Music]
wooden bag
Annabelle would hate you Christy would
hate you and I would hate you being
talked about next on this list is
talking Tina from an episode of The
Twilight Zone Tina was featured in the
episode called living doll which aired
on November 1st 1963 during the fifth
and final season of The Twilight Zone in
it Telly Savalas and Mary LaRoche play
Eric and Annabelle Schrader there's that
name Annabelle again it's everywhere
their dysfunctional family is made worse
when she buys their daughter a wind-up
doll named talky Tina that ends up being
sentient the toy seems nice at first but
Crossing her proves especially deadly
oh
so you had a feeling it doesn't
everything
then I can hurt you
could hurt you
the doll they use for Tina was produced
at a place called Vogue doll company
sometime in the late 50s to early 60s
and marketed under the name briquette
but since briquette wasn't a talking
doll Tina's on-screen portrayal is
modeled more after the popular Mattel
doll chatty Kathy and wouldn't you know
it the person who provided the voice for
the chatty Kathy dolls is the same
person who provided the voice for
talking Tina the legendary June Foray
the award-winning actress with a star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame was also the
voice of iconic characters like Rocky
the Flying Squirrel Lucifer the cat from
Cinderella and Cindy Lou Who and she's
credited with helping establish both the
Academy Award for best animated feature
and the Annie Awards too so like dang
you go to talkatina and despite
appearing in just this one episode of
The Twilight Zone Tina has lived on in
the pop culture ethos being parodied by
shows like The Simpsons Johnny Bravo and
Sabrina the Teenage Witch throughout the
years among others the doll has also
been said to be one of The Inspirations
for Chucky from Child's Play and also
the character of Gabby Gabby in 2019's
Toy Story 4. according to that film's
director Josh Cooley so hey that's quite
the Legacy for talkatina
fats Magic
foreign
next on this list of the scariest evil
dolls of Cinema is fats from 1978's
Magic the psychological horror flick was
directed by Richard Attenborough with a
screenplay by William Goldman who also
wrote the 1976 novel upon which the
movie was based the film stars Anthony
Hopkins as Corky a failed magician who
starts to find success after picking up
a new ventriloquist act with an abrasive
dummy named fats but as the idea of
success takes its toll on corki's mental
state that seems to take on a mind of
his own the rude and vulgar fats who was
designed to specifically and very
creepily look like Hopkins is basically
the sociopathic Alter Ego of corki who
suffers from mental disorders and uses
fats to comfort himself
hello everybody this is Mrs Norman Maine
my mother thank you my father thank you
my sister thanks unai thank you you have
nothing to fear but fear itself nothing
to give my Blood Sweat and Tears nothing
to lose but you changed every year spies
here he is World Earth facts
big stars of the time like Jack
Nicholson Robert De Niro and Gene Wilder
were kicked around as possible choices
for Corky before Hopkins was cast and of
course Hopkins would go on to play
Hannibal Lecter in Silence of the Lambs
so Hopkins took the part and he ran with
it learning magic tricks and studying
the art of ventriloquism to prepare for
the part he even took the doll from the
movie home with him to work on some
things as well but he got so creeped out
by it that the director Attenborough had
to come pick it up and calm Hopkins down
in the middle of the night it seems to
be all worth it though as the corkian
fats roll earned Hopkins bafta and
Golden Globe nominations for his
performance and that's the doll has
lingered on in pop culture serving as
R.L Stein's inspiration for the doll
named Slappy of course in his popular
children's Horror Story series
Goosebumps blade Puppet Master
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sharpening things up next on this list
is Blade from 1989's Puppet Master
directed by David schmoller this film
centers around four psychics who are
plotted against by a former colleague
that committed suicide after he
discovers murderous puppets animated by
an Egyptian spell one of those puppet
dolls blade is considered to be the
leader and is the most popular of the
group among fans it's one of only a few
to have appeared in every Puppet Master
film in the franchise and the only one
to appear on all of the DVD and Blu-ray
covers so in other words he is the face
of the franchise
[Music]
the doll weighs in at four pounds and
stands one foot nine inches tall
requiring five puppeteers to operate and
he's pretty much going full Gothic with
a black trench coat and wide brim hat to
go with his gaunt pale face eerily empty
black eye sockets and long white hair
blade which is apparently based on one
of director schmuller's favorite actors
Klaus Kinski has a knife for his right
hand and a sharp hook for his left
paired with the occasional spiking
bullet-like eyes that pop out of his
sockets I don't think Klaus has those
things but I could be wrong on that
after bypassing a theatrical summer
opening in lieu of a direct-to-video
release in the fall of 89 Puppet Master
went on to develop a large cult
following not to mention a full-blown
franchise and when I say franchise we're
talking five sequels that follow this
first movie and in 2020 because blade is
clearly the best of these evil dolls he
got his own spin-off film called Blade
the Iron Cross
Brahms the boy
and the final installment on this list
of the scariest evil dolls of Cinema is
Brahms from 2016's the boy this horror
mystery thriller was directed by William
Brent Bell and stars Lauren Cohen as a
young American hiding from her abusive
ex in the English Countryside she's
desperate enough to take a job as a
nanny for a boy that's actually just a
doll named Brahms owned by parents who
are coping with the alleged loss of
their son 20 years earlier the doll
begins to move positions and do other
scary things that leads her to think
that it's somehow alive but then we
discover that the doll is actually just
entertainment and a cover for the
couple's son Brahms who is not actually
dead but rather hiding in the wall since
he killed a little girl at the age of
eight
foreign
[Music]
the human-like doll with a pale face
dark hair and dressed nicely is meant to
resemble the actual boy Brahms who was
played by jet Klein in this film Klein
would go on to play Tommy maximoff in
the MCU and it turns out the Brahms doll
also served a purpose behind the scenes
as well as cast members would use it to
prank each other on set at one point one
of the actors got so freaked out that
they threw the doll outside of their
trailer and caused damage to the doll
prompting the crew to also create a
replacement doll Brahms the doll's run
of Terror didn't end with this movie
though a sequel Brahms The Boy 2 was
released in 2020 with Katie Holmes this
time in the lead role and an expanded
story for the doll that reveals him to
in fact be alive and demon-possessed how
about that we did it our list of the
scariest dolls of Cinema do you have a
favorite do let us know and the next
time you're browsing the doll section at
your local toy store those are still a
thing right I think they are be sure to
think of us and this list won't you
please thanks so much for tuning in to
RT Essentials I'm your host Perry
nemroth and now I have to go home and
hang out with the Chucky doll that truly
lips on my couch goodbye
[Music]